fam should send me this long thing
justifications and all and then the only
price you would get is that strike one
two more and you're out fam that's
strike one
I don't know where your head's at enjoy
your anniversary that's true I'll see
you when you get home that's strike one
right
[Music]
as you already know guys we go straight
into the juicy woosy Boosie and the
question of the week this week was
what's the craziest thing you've done to
get your crush's attention as per usual
craziest thing you've done to get your
crushes attention Jesus okay as you
already know gushing down the lips
gushing down the juicy juice juicy wussy
everything Lucy cool had my friend do a
girls night with his girlfriend so I
could bang him
let me say that again had my friend do a
girls night with his girlfriend so I
could bang him
wow
wow yeah that's a turn I'm not gonna lie
there's something demonic to me that's
that's Eternal he's a turtle but it's
treacherous yes treacherous she's
recognizing all sorts to hold the wood
um
sang to her in front of our drama class
she said I'm a good singer but I
couldn't be with someone like you
from Ramadan just like breaking out in
soccer yeah doing up Dramatics in public
yeah there's music there's no way we can
be together I can't do this High School
yeah can't be seen with someone like you
sent him me singing a cover of Marvin
Gaye this the lover on Facebook and he
replied Orcs
he just replied oh don't send me nothing
like that bro Orcs
that's that's a chance I'm not gonna lie
I couldn't finish this oh I couldn't get
through the whole team yeah yeah oh oh
God
raised my boy to hold the door open she
didn't even walk through she looked at
me and said yuck oh
raced my boy I need to get this door
open for this girl and he told him he
didn't even walk through so she said
yuck and just turned around turn around
and went elsewhere
you might know embarrassing yourselves
yuck the thing is what's mad is that
like you just don't know that in the
moment because I'm I'm picturing it now
two even if they were banging two
linkedins could never race to a door to
open it for me yeah yeah yeah yeah
because immediately you're a three yeah
now what is going on what is going on
here like you don't rate yourself like
what what is this that makes perfect
sense yeah yeah that makes perfect sense
yeah
followed and unfollowed him countless
times I did get his attention he blocked
me oh right found this immediate thing I
was thinking and there's actually
someone who's been doing that I'll swear
someone that's been doing that bro and
like um not it's not even a girl as a
guy okay I'm not gonna bet I'm not gonna
pay him out okay
um but there's a guy that was trying to
get my attention not even in a gay way I
don't know to be fair cool to be fair
but he was following me and unfollowing
me for time oh really follow me on this
is a known person oh really follow me on
for me for like two weeks and I was like
stop brother are you serious I had to
follow him back just to stop the drama
you caved into peer pressure I caved
into peer pressure but when I tell you
who it was you'll know why oh say let's
tell me the money was on the line
so thank me later
I let him hide from his wife at my place
wow
I let him hide from his the women are
way worse bro the women are way worse
hide from his wife at my place I did
this because he's my crush ah they don't
respect the sanctity of a relationship
at all
it's fine I'm not mad at it yeah but wow
it's a wow indeed
made her cry because she couldn't spell
English wasn't her first language
this is what they did for their Crush I
made her cry because she can't spell
yeah oh he's trying to do a little yeah
yeah yeah yeah little cheeky you're sexy
but I'm gonna bully you too yeah
probably just cried Primary School yeah
laughed at a joke he said from across
the room he looked over at me oh sorry
she looked over at me and said what are
you laughing at
what are you laughing at
I couldn't be confronted by my crush
with that kind of noise what are you
laughing at what are you laughing at
you you're funny what are you laughing
at
yeah I can't yeah
started a fight in front of her I got
knocked out [ __ ] happens
bro
and what planet is that is and what
planet is that doing it for a girl
start in a fight with someone alcohol
must have been involved because oh
you're right you can't have yourself
yeah yeah when you're when you're when
you're drunk you actually do resort to
like your most primal
initiatives your instincts like you're
just like yeah if I beat a guy up like
she's going to be it's going to be gas
that she knows I'm a protector and a
provider yeah I'm strong yeah like I'm a
man and I'm strong that's what she's
looking for the alpha and he got rocks
he said [ __ ] happens it literally does
happen you just have to move on to the
next question yep yep he ghosted me so I
joined the church group at his house
that's invasive
he ghosted me so I joined the church
group at his house brother
that's yo she couldn't walk in my room
she could walk in my yard
after I've been after I've
made it adamant that yo we're not even
about this fam this is why we don't do
Church groups at our houses this is what
churches are for
eign
[Applause]
a bit of serious issues
all right what have you what's the
craziest thing you've done to get your
crush's attention I touched his hand and
he didn't notice so I kicked him
Fam I'm attracted to you acknowledge me
acknowledge that I just tossed your hand
why are you why have you got goosebumps
answer me just literally answer me
Legend imagine yuck
try to square up to her dad wake up at a
hold himself the next morning turns out
her dad's a cop
that's foolishness all of that is just
again I'll call it juicy mustard yeah
yeah so much
who's winning here
that's a loser let's get started you
rocket Adam what what he's not gonna
date you yeah I've just beat my dad up
like what are we talking about here
literally Oh my days hid his inhaler
when he was having an asthma attack and
gave him mine instead
that I could never find that out
I'm searching
I'm like just searching for my inhaler I
just need a puff I just need one pop
quick
where is it where is it I scrambling
where is it in a back pocket don't worry
use mine use mine I'm like oh my God
thank you thank you so much thank you so
much
[Laughter]
where is mine but thank you I couldn't
find out she stole it
ah just so just so I can see you can
save my life just so we can chat and we
have a little meet cute nah your mom nah
nah kidnap their cat and when she was
posted when she started putting up
missing posters I came back with it to
her house of course she did of course
she did that actually would work that
definitely would work well that's that's
long oh it's long long day yeah because
you're I'm obviously good I'm obviously
pulling up with scratches over my face
so I need to stop her side yeah Rags
Rags she's
try to drift my car in front of her I
ended up tipping her over I woke up in
ER
mass that I woke up there raw he had no
idea what happened I woke up in the yard
sweetened me oh the [ __ ] sake we hit
me man them think well there's a there's
a bunch of hoodlums that like are
located in like my local Tesco
bunch of hoodless bunch of hoodlums and
they've all got Fiat 500s with fat
exhausts oh God and they think they
[ __ ] oh these men think they [ __ ] bro
yeah and they're just like what are you
man on yeah that's exactly the device
I'm getting yeah because these men were
just red for the sake of it it's 1am at
Tesco and I'm running in to get like
whatever hand lotion or something and
I'm just seeing them Man all parts in a
circle all parts of the circle bro and
it's just like yeah like it's West Side
Story just revving bro rev and skidding
and they're thinking yes
yes
bro this is a vehicle this is a vehicle
it's noisy
suck me off Rags yeah what are you
waiting for yeah yeah and the repeating
of it was is I had to drive through
their little fire Circle one time
because they just blocked the exits oh
so I'm not playing this game yeah I left
drove through their little [ __ ] old
Circle one of their one of their hoes
yeah clocked me and was like James James
James James James I looked at all the
other little magpies and they're all
like James
and obviously I was livid at the same
time I was thinking your man's need to
see this yeah yeah yeah they need to see
this because it's exhausted it's not
gonna last I don't know what's going on
you need a real man in the real car
ladies you need a real man and a real
car that's what you need none of this
Tesco Drive bikes yeah you managed to
pattern up that's true
nice
was it the same week as Central C no no
no no that would have months ago
after I would have fixed everything it
would have fixed everything if it was
the same month
it would have fixed everything that's
hilarious that's hilarious I've only got
a couple more that's the craziest thing
you've done to get your crush's
attention
saw he was at a wedding on Insta and
then I turned up as his plus one
what do you mean as what
um just turn up I'm your plus one
don't worry and then you're just gonna
come up and sit next to me listen to me
cause that's
crazy explain yourself because I came on
my ones and you're here and your excuses
I saw your post on Insta did my makeup
my hair and got a dress on because it
looked like you needed a plus one yeah I
came as a as possible I came as myself
I'm leaving as myself like this this
plus one thing is
wow bro I'd alert someone
I tap the groom or the bride like yo
she's not bro I don't know who this
Invader is she's crashing the tank
literally a wedding yeah she's throwing
my name under the bus bro I'm not
associated yeah yeah Dead all of that
wow that's crazy bro try to do a trick
on my BMX while she whilst he was there
and I broke my foot in three places
whilst he was there it was the chick on
the BMX she was trying to do bits I mean
that's a turn on to be fair if she
Landed It
if she's laying and she's doing BMX bits
obviously you're having a broken foot
chaos like you're never gonna hear from
me again three places yeah I didn't know
that was possible bro yeah neither did I
thought you'd break your foot you don't
you break or you don't what's three
places yeah yeah snap to Pieces nah
she's not walking around that's icky
yeah I could never like just be at a
skate park doing a baggy jeans
yeah
the little keychain thing that goes past
money and I'm going out my hand and
slicked it across my hair yeah and I'm
just yeah I'm doing a mascara yeah and
I've got a bad [ __ ] trying to show me
tricks yeah yeah she's got a little
little Gap
she tries to pull a trick foot snaps
onto there because it must be three
places it got caught under the wheel
yeah her foot got caught under the wheel
she just flew off it yeah she screamed
that day immediate yuck I'm gonna call
someone to help you yuck yeah I don't
want to see you in this radius again
yeah yeah and it's actually dread
because like
this is a male saturated sport so in
order to get my attention you have to do
better than everyone Rags you're not
allowed to learn here learn at home and
be amazing by the time you're trying to
like get me hard off this yeah but I'm
gonna be gone by then so yeah yeah
exactly to the next one yeah exactly
because there's um there's actually a
skateboarder that I follow called some
Brazilian thing her name's like it
begins with l
let's issue like buffoni or something
like that okay hang but she's even more
paying because she's amazing at
skateboarding okay she's like good level
of pain but she's like unreal because
like she's banging at skateboarding okay
it's just the sexiest thing okay okay
okay is it is the tissue performing yeah
lenting pink hair
yeah physique and then sometimes she'll
just do some surfing just on a Wednesday
because like because she can yeah say
less because she's sponsored by whoever
and she can yeah yes
she spots a deep fat fish she's got
proper monster she might responds about
Nike or sign oh mad yeah she's a she's
fat okay she's bad so less yeah
um speaking of that's the end of Aji
that's then yeah
um
I said this ages ago but I might revisit
it I might be a bit old for it but I'm
certain like skateboarding might be my
calling you said you did say this before
said it ages ago it was a throwaway
comment because I know like my obsession
like I just will start not coming to
work do you know what I mean because
like I'll be too obsessed with it yeah
yeah I'd be too obsessed with it and all
of a sudden we'll be like what guesses
on this week yeah and I'm like oh this
is very Niche skateboarding kid from
Brighton who's crushing up and coming in
the scene you just have to get it yeah
he's been on the cover of skate like
three months in a row and I'm obsessed
with him he has to come on and you're
like what is this what are we talking
all of a sudden it's a skating podcast
so I'm like all right can't do
skateboarding because I'll get obsessed
with it okay but then I was thinking
about the other day and I thought you
know [ __ ] it I might have to get into
skateboarding okay because like the
learning curve is steep and I love being
like I love being [ __ ] at stuff and
getting good at it
um
and skateboarding is so cool you do used
to skateboard when you're a kid right or
no oh no I skateboarded like twice when
I was a kid oh I had a skateboard I
skateboard I was good Define used to
skateboard could you do a kickflip no so
you did a skateboard so I could skate
that's like level one yeah
but then again I I didn't
I couldn't do tricks yeah like I just
never learned I'll never practice Yeah
say less I'm trying yeah I'm trying to
be I'm trying to be a little I'm not I'm
not allowed I don't think I'm a
half-pipe guy oh God no no no no no yeah
I would like to be like a little just
subtle just subtle Peng yeah just like
this guy is built like a brick [ __ ]
house he's he's mature he's got title on
his neck Lang light-skinned laying his
Shape Up stay strong length and he's
just skateboarding but he's probably
[ __ ] and then like I just I'm just there
like minding my business it's one of
them as you hold it in your hand you
just take three steps yeah drop it and
then back that's what I want to do drop
it and glide off and when you hold it by
the nose the lip and you just Dash [ __ ]
gliding through yeah two strong steps
you see a little curb yeah just a little
and then and then I'm in Reverse I land
in reverse and I'm just like wait what
huh
what happened that's what I want say
less I secretly really want that and I
know that's six years of work for that
one little thing yeah but like I I want
it bad okay because that's one of the
ones where I like I'd like that will
become my personality okay yeah yeah
he'll call my personality and all of a
sudden like I've just got like half an
afro one day because it's just what the
culture I'm in now ah I really wish this
this comes to pass so I could see you in
the mini afro yeah bro because obviously
now I've got white friends and they want
to touch my hair foreign
[Laughter]
Houston was on there
when he was like 11. he was on the game
he had dreadlocks do you remember
yeah yeah he had dreadlocks and now he's
just like the guy which I thought was
sick he's in a pro skater game when he
was a huge
I think I remember him now that you said
yeah dreads yeah I think I remember yeah
I remember he's you when you when you
when you played I can't remember what
it's called but you would play like this
like the uh
the little competition where you have
where you have to highlight all the
obstacles in your color do you remember
you have to land a trick on a thing yeah
yeah and if they can get a higher score
remember it's theirs it's theirs yeah
and you have red versus blue hard I
remember Nigel used to Mark me on that
it's little you bro I've used to murk me
on that game and I used to think [ __ ]
and I swear isn't the same one or a
different game where you could you have
to find the letter skate or skate you
have to find it yeah yeah yeah that's
yeah exactly oh I had times on that game
at times on that game I think pro pro
skate three cover what's called Tony
Hawk three something like that and I had
uh Tiger Woods PGA Tour oh really oh you
can get lost in there boy oh really
you'll get lost in there boy yeah that
was fun okay yeah I'll never ever ever
played any golf games oh good fun okay
wholesome family fun family fun um
anyway guys welcome back welcome back
welcome welcome back it is episode two
four nine we're on the cusp of 250 and
if you want to watch 250 you will find
it on patreon.com forward slash shits
and gigs and it's gonna cost you a
measly light humble three pound a month
10p a day all you need to do is run that
P to SMG and you'll get Thursday's
episode as well as three plus years of
content over on patreon it will give you
access to our Discord Channel disco
Channel where everyone just Boogie Yugi
in over there you get invitations to our
monthly Zoom call you have a great time
but anyway guys patreon.com shits and
gigs and become an official cult baby
yes sir
um as well as that guys if you are
watching us on YouTube please subscribe
to the channel we are desperately trying
to hit 500k subscribers so that would be
Peng that would be very paying and then
we'll chat about Millie after that
um and obviously guys if you are
listening on your Spotify your Apple
podcast if you're listening on Amazon
music whatever you listen to please
please give us a review five stars is
obviously preferable but whatever you
say say it with your chest and let's
just get on with it well boys no matter
what okay
um and yeah man New Year
I wanted to talk about a couple
resolution things okay
um I think we did this last year we
might have you know Jeff
of dread because I'm gonna need to
listen back to that because I don't
think I'll follow through with anything
unless unless unless my New Year's
resolution was to make money
yeah yeah
I think that was our only New Year's
resolution unless yeah unless my uh
resolution was to like yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
get money they live lavish live lavish
yeah they're not resolution ticks I
don't think that made it past January oh
God
I got crossed out
um now I'm playing I'm not but yeah
um but not I need to listen back because
I don't know what else other resolutions
I stick by I definitely had a gym one
which
I would have had I would have stuck to
it for a time and then we had a we've
had this year has been a roller coaster
year of
James father's health is concerned true
true just just a bunch of chat and [ __ ]
and faking it to make it yep I
definitely had the no procrastination
one which I've definitely didn't live up
to definitely didn't live up to yeah I'm
gonna make Okay cool so I'm gonna I'm
gonna throw a few out there okay and see
what sticks this one I don't think it's
gonna stick and it's a heinous one a
heinous one but if I can stick to it I
promise you 2024 is going to be I'm
gonna be operating on a different level
okay I don't want to see porn this year
I don't want to see it I want flesh and
blood and I want to use my think you
think if I have to fap I want to use my
highlight reel yeah and but for the most
part I want Flesh and Blood okay
do you know what I mean
[Laughter]
I want skin yeah I want connections I
want chemistry yeah I want love making
yeah yeah I want real life
this yeah yeah and I don't want visuals
I want yeah you know what I want you I
hear you yeah I want babes I want lips
in a missionary you know what I mean
yeah
yeah I don't wanna yeah if I don't want
to waste nuts anymore wasting nuts and
tissue and socks whatever I can get my
hand on
like whatever the closest material
exactly when like yeah when push comes
to shut up so I mean
can you say you let it fly or fit it oh
yeah it lands on my chest it lands in
the dead of night land straight on my
stomach
and I hate it you just rolling yeah
and then afterwards obviously you're
like oh yuck yeah yeah it's the same to
be fair it's the same as I treat my my
faps like I treat like my nuts because
when we're into it yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you bang bang and then after you
like
and sometimes if your trousers are here
like if your child is just past the
knees yeah
spontaneous nut oh yeah I'm taking it
off brother I need to be comfortable nah
bro I'm talking about for a quickie
quickie sneaky quickies you never know
so wait you're talking about socks on
t-shirt on
and just charge us off
so your ass naked on a cricket so if you
were like baby babe and you'd put a
house against the wall you're just Arts
naked she's turning around and she don't
know what happened because you're just
naked I'm not gonna be naked and then
I'm gonna take her clothes off no no
what I'm saying is is like say okay cool
say spontaneous thing let me fit a
picture for you yeah yeah yeah we're
walking from the I don't know we're on
our way out
we're on our way out somewhere and
you're thinking um she's looking good
and we're not going to be able to clap
cheeks for like four hours because we're
about to do activities and then you're
getting a bit flare like oh you look
alright she's like you look alright and
you're like you smell good you're Rock
Solid
you're Rock Solid yeah and then like you
just give her a little hands on the wall
lips in the neck and you're thinking now
we're banging yeah we're banging
so you give her a little pull down a
little slide to the side I'm I'm here
and I'm reaching for wood and we're just
going to slide in and bang you're
telling me in this moment you're about
to go out yeah
socks off shoes off trousers off t-shirt
off chain off watch off
um I would definitely take my tea off
I'm I'm doing nothing I'll definitely
I'm definitely taking my shirt off
um because you could just get Mucky down
there yeah he's just here this way
so I'm thinking I'm taking off my shirt
regardless
jewelry can stay on yeah yeah it is the
gold on skin on your black skin yeah
my God on your [ __ ] black skin that's
juicy
don't kill me bro don't kill me
you made money in it that's crazy
yeah to be thinking about it now if it's
if it's one of them ones because
one of them ones where we're about to go
out and pulling it to the side
yeah it will probably just be a one one
position trousers down top definitely
off yeah and just bang till I come say
yes
but top definitely coming off okay
dependent like my I might take the top
off or I might do a chin
because I want a grease I want a lips
I'm the same because like but that's
just laziness not because of that's
that's not optimal because
don't ah this is a weird one I've never
spoke to you about this
when you're back shot him with a t-shirt
on and a t-shirt is like clapping the
ass as well yeah it stops the ass from
touching your skin it causes physical
pain
do you ever feel that
if the ass ain't touching my skin I have
to move the T-shirt I'll Rags I can't
take it yeah yeah yeah because it's not
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
know exactly I've done chin and it's
dropped and I'm here I'm just okay
see this will have to back your order
yeah it's a disturbance yeah from now on
it's always coming off yeah the shirt
has to come off because when it when it
creates a barrier between cheeks and
skin I promise it causes me pain I know
you can't handle it yeah yeah fair play
um okay cool oh resolutions
I forgot we got lost wow yeah wow how
did it even get onto that
porn oh yeah
blood skin blood bone
with that I went last a week but I'm
saying if I can because if I can make it
a week I can make it a month no no if I
can make it a week I make it two weeks
yeah make it two weeks I can make it a
month if I make it a month I can make it
three if I can make it three I can make
a six and then once I've made it six I
promise you're not watching porn
um but if I can get off it get away from
it
I'll be happy man I'll be a very very
happy man uh and I'll just be operating
better speaking of
we can actually try it there's a we can
do like an accountability thing someone
told me about a like a pawn blocking
type thing where obviously all your
devices and stuff won't you'd have to
sign up to whatever all your devices you
won't be able to go and put like um like
a privacy like we have on internet now
but if you wanted to go on it for
example you'd have to text me for a code
and obviously I would give you that oh
we could do something like that we can
do that I can't remember like the full
details but it intrigued me the day you
told me about it gang I need to find out
about that okay
gang at least Aaron find that for me
please yeah oh because I'm not I can't
ask you for that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
give me the code give me that give me
the code
give me the code I need it I need ASAP
I'm desperate yeah and because the thing
is as well is like it'll be good because
once you've given in and giving me the
code I'm not horny anymore oh yeah yeah
it's just like it's like what are you
doing James what are you doing bro you
just have to argue with your boy for a
porn code
bro
[Laughter]
and the thing is it won't be half an
hour later I mean 30 seconds later
verb you'll be 30 seconds later you
won't even the the what's that would
have even hit two ticks and I'm already
like why'd you give me the code bro
you'd be thinking wrong
um Okay cool so yeah no Pawn
I bought and uh well not an official but
I bought like a portable tub because I
want to have an ice baths okay I want to
start having an ice bath every morning
okay it's meant to Bam wake you up then
apparently there was a study where a guy
like called himself a prostate cancer oh
that's not what I thought you were gonna
say oh okay okay
um something to do with like there's a
I listened to what maybe like Joe Rogan
or something but there was a guy
who
had like anomalies or like high levels
of something that was like a precursor
to prostate cancer and they were gonna
have to take a biopsy and like I don't
know like prostate cancer in men is like
a it's a death sentence
[Music]
um so he started doing he did some
research and he was like gang he started
doing ice baths every morning for like
three minutes at a time
um first thing in the morning and along
with a lot of other stuff like nutrition
and and water and sleep and all that
stuff but like yeah ice baths and then
when it when the next time came and they
did tests they were like bro I don't
know what's happened but your patterned
you're nice they're supposed to have
crazy health benefits crazy crazy health
benefits um I bought myself a tub yeah
um it's been in the Box for like two
weeks I'm not gonna lie to you it's been
the books for like two weeks okay but
um yeah I'm gonna crack out a box I'm
gonna start like I'm putting ice on in
the first day I'm just gonna fill it up
with cold water leave it outside and I'm
gonna get in it and then progressively
get colder and colder and then if I can
pattern it for like months I'll invest
in like a proper proper ice bath okay
that you can like set like they cost
bags you can set the temperature and it
actually has like ice and it starts
creating ice it's so cold you're getting
there three minutes a day and I feel
like even just the apparently the
endorphin rush it gives you and the
dopamine for like the next eight hours
is like wild I'll swear it makes you
change your mood
madly yeah because it literally is a
shock to the system yeah crazy so yeah
I'm gonna try and do that and um again
I'll be guessed if I can do that cool
I'll be gassed if I can do that oh okay
um and what else you got I think I'm
gonna dedicate this year I dedicated a
dedicated 2022 to work
um but I'm going to dedicate 2023 to
like
I want to be more present with work and
like obviously when we're recording yeah
I'm present but like I have like I've
got into this weird Funk of like putting
stuff off and like not action and stuff
um
and being like yeah I'll get to it yeah
I'll get to it and yeah I'll do this and
like stressing myself out and like in
the big scheme of things if you compare
if I compare my schedule to someone who
actually has a 40 hour work week yeah
like mine is nothing in comparison yeah
so there's no reason why I can't be
dedicated like outside of here like 10
hours a week to actually doing stuff and
getting stuff done and I want to like
stick to doing like I want every day I
want to have to-do list and every day I
want everything on that to do just to be
ticked I want to know my schedule like
crazy I want to know my schedule like my
PA would know my schedule I want to know
exactly what I'm doing and the times
I've got to do it like days in advance
so that like I'm not ever rushing around
and stuff like that and like I wanna
because obviously me and RAM have calls
most the time on a Monday and we do have
them it's good because I can tell I tell
him my schedule and when I'm telling him
my schedule for the week is the first
time that I even know it oh yes it's
reminding you I'm just going through it
myself and then I'm looking as I'm
telling him and it helps me because
there'll be times where I'm like I might
end up having the back of my mind oh
I'll get to this and I'll tell Ram like
oh Thursday I'm unavailable and I'll be
like raw Thursday I'm unavailable yeah
that means I need today I need to work
bro because I'm not getting anything
done or like Tuesday I'm I'm in London
from this time to this time and I'm
thinking [ __ ] actually my week's
actually pretty busy yeah like whatever
work I need to do I need to get done
today and like so I need to be a little
bit more cognizant of that and like
present and actually when I'm doing work
like
feel the energy like feel like
the perfectionism of it and not just get
stuff done and get it out and all this
stuff like actually feel it like really
really really really feel it and our
dinner tonight's going to help me with
that massively
um I've got some stuff that I want to
talk to about to you about at dinner I'm
really really excited about so and I
think like once that's written in stone
um I'm gonna be like wow okay of course
go time it's go time it's go time so
yeah I think for me yeah we'll say that
no Pawn won't last
um I'll be killing you for the code yeah
um ice baths yeah and what else I say
presents present just presence of Mind
in everything that I do presence and
like given everything I do 100 yeah if I
choose to do something I want to do it
do it do it yeah yeah cool that's mine
mine is definitely still the same as
last year and procrastination I'm a
massive procrastin AR
um so same as yourself I want to like
when I do have to-do lists and I checked
I actually check them off I feel so
fulfilled so fulfilled but I'm not I
will leave something until the last
minute if I have to or if I can yeah
yeah and it's just it's such a bad trait
to have so I'm going to try my best to
not procrastinate if I think oh I want
to do even if it's something as light as
uh just getting up to do this and do
that in my yard
I'm not just get up and [ __ ] do it
you know what I mean get up and do it
bro this morning
I woke up at uh nine o'clock yeah which
was earlier than I needed to I didn't
leave my bed till 10. I was on Tick Tock
I brought bro I was on Instagram and
tick tocking from nine until 10. I do
that so much so much it was 10 I was
like what are you doing bro
I could have done productive stuff yeah
yeah and that happens with me almost
every morning because I wake up it's
pretty early-ish nowadays
um so I wake up between like eight and
ten and this morning I actually knew I
had to do stuff so
um I made my food I made my breakfast
and I made my pre um my pre-prep meal
for the rest of the week so I knew I had
stuff to do and I had to wash the dishes
blah blah I was active so I had already
thought about that the night before I
was thinking okay cool I'm gonna do this
this and this and I felt great doing it
you know I mean I knew my stuff was done
pretty much done for the day yeah yeah
so I'm gonna make sure every morning
when I wake up because I'm always in bed
in the morning I've got unless we have
like job Studio yeah yeah
every morning I'm gonna dedicate at
least an hour to the Pod oh whether it
be replying to DMS because I've said
this to you in the past I've said this
to you in the past so many times I'm
gonna take some time out reply to the
M's do this or do that research whatever
I can spend an hour on my phone replying
to DMS you'll give me hundreds I will
fly by yeah so little things like that
and make a massive difference a huge
difference a huge difference
and that in turn could potentially give
me ideas
um of different stuff you need to
because of stuff I might read fun facts
I've got a game that I want to try with
you next week okay gang I thought about
it literally yesterday okay I've got
everything all written out so I'm going
to try the next week so little things
like that I want to try and make sure my
procrastination levels are nil okay
absolutely Jim is what the consistency
of Jim is always going to be one every
single year but with the way the trading
program is going and the way my diet is
good like
um the PT actually messes me in between
these two episodes yeah yeah
so yeah
um I'm gonna try and make sure I'm
continuing with that
um and see where I can actually take my
body too obviously it's not I don't want
to compete I'll do any of that but I
just want to see where I can take my
body to like I've never I've never seen
myself be like damn this is Peak
physique so I want to get to that stage
and
um
those are my two Mains to be fair those
are my two Mains but everything else in
terms of um what we're going to talk
about later on today um at dinner
obviously those will be the Pod related
ones okay ping all right right uh you've
got trash news right yes I do you've
seen you heard about your boy Samuel L
Jackson
[ __ ] I didn't read into it yeah but I
saw the title man
people were messaging him or like outing
him on Twitter being like bro
all I saw was that people trying to warn
him that is he's baiting himself out for
liking hardcore porn on Twitter yep yeah
wow liking it you know he's old
Twitter's a danger
place and the thing about it because
porn on Twitter could just pop up on
anyone's timeline yeah oh okay I was on
I was on Twitter not too long ago the
other day actually I was scrolling
through scrolling I can't remember where
I was
but I think I may have been in the gym
like in between sets and stuff it's just
scrolling through scrolling through then
I scrolled once and it was a video of
just cheeks just voluptuous cheeks and
you could you can get caught yeah
and like was liking it you know that's
hilarious to me just voluptuous cheeks I
was thinking and I just kept on
scrolling thinking I'm in a public sale
like anyone could appeal that anyone
could have just assumed because the way
Twitter is it it can bring up anything
oh okay yeah yeah so and the dangerous
thing about liking stuff it's not like a
retweet anymore liking projects that
stuff onto other people's Pages
like so and so so it acts like a retweet
at the same time not so yeah man them
Twitter porn you need to be careful
scroll on the left side not the right
scroll on the left side because the
light the lighting is on the right hand
side scroll to the left that's hilarious
anyway let me read this uh fans want
Samuel Jackson after you spotted liking
hardcore porn on Twitter Jackson who
turned 20 uh 24. he turned 74 yesterday
started training on Twitter after he
uses realized his account had been
liking some pre-x-rated adult film
content
um unsurprisingly the likes have since
disappeared but the screenshots are the
screen records on Twitter remain the
same of course it could have been anyone
who liked the posts as it's hard to
believe Jackson doesn't have a
management or public and publicity team
either run his account or at least have
access to it then there's also the
possibility that he was hacked
but yeah that's the he won Heights
that's the thing it says black Panda
something something
oh allow it bro
74. Peak bro oh black Panda wow Samuel
said yum he said yum just just like and
stuff oh he's so old it's so big the
liking of it is hilarious to me yeah the
liking of it and just just can't help
himself I'm saying that could have been
an accident that could have that can
happen accident could have been an
accident because that I've accidentally
called people on Instagram because I'm
on my phone yeah yeah or I could be on
Instagram but I get a um a WhatsApp
message and it comes up and I try and
swipe up I miss it by mistake yeah you
just call him Randomness on Instagram
this happened but they would have been
gassed as well things happen oh that's
embarrassing yeah poor poor from him oh
yeah yeah but yeah you can get lost in
that rabbit hole Yeah you can you can
easily especially a 74 year old man he's
seen he ain't seen stuff like that every
day oh Rags bro so yeah you'll get
you'll get lost deep in it deep in it
happens um right you had a question for
me as well today no I do have a question
for you all right I'm excited
um this came about because I was
watching
um David Letterman's
um
this person needs no introduction but my
next guest my next guest on Netflix yeah
yeah yeah yeah I watched one with uh
Ryan Reynolds not too long oh okay very
interesting very uh intriguing he's
obviously right you you get to realize
Ryan Reynolds plays Ryan Reynolds in
every Ryan Reynolds movie kind of thing
yeah yeah yeah there was a part where he
was talking about
his family and stuff and something to do
he brought up his wife Blake Blake
Lively those I don't know
um and it made me question
how
how whether they can tell people are
telling the truth or not so my question
to you is
if you're a successful actor and if you
are married or dating another successful
act or actress would you know whether
they're lying to you or not
oh God
because in any given scenario they can
switch up
um
I think I would know
but I don't necessarily think it would
be down to
because they're an actor or not an actor
I think like with the lying thing is
that like most people know other people
are lying based on like
the physical like symptoms of lying like
the same way you can get caught on a lie
detector like I don't think an actor
is more likely to pass a lie detector
than someone who's not an actor yeah
that's but that's we're talking about
machines now that's different of course
no but what I'm saying is because that's
based on like
heart rate and like yeah yeah so like I
feel like there will be like some
physical symptoms that you you can pick
up on
but
I don't know bro like I said to you
Charles are probably not but I also
don't think I'm very good at like
picking up when normal people are lying
okay I've been lied to in my life I
think that we all have and I just I'm
just a typically trusting person yeah so
and sometimes I also this is like
obviously a controversial thing but we
spoke about 100 times like sometimes I
think lies are just there to benefit
people and like um it depends what
you're lying about Etc et cetera but
like
absolutely I I want to be lied to I want
to be lied to all the time like I just
want to live uh literally ignorant
lovely Pleasant life and if that
involves being lied to by all the bad
things in the world like
telling kids that Santa's real makes
Christmas awesome do you know what I
mean like telling kids Easter Bunny is
hiding your eggs you have to go find
them makes Easter awesome like lies can
be beneficial and like
if that makes like can you imagine what
a sick world we would live in if
you just thought Santa was real forever
do you not think it would like bring
extra joy in your life I know that
there's actually a magical man out there
that drops presents to your yard based
on your the way based on the morals on
which you live your life if you've been
on a nice or naughty list
if you're gonna get gifts on Christmas
or not if like adults just believe that
as well yeah
like I just think the world would be a
better place
I agree I just find it hard to believe
that it could be a plausibility oh no no
no it can't be a possibly I'm not saying
it can be I'm just saying in a
hypothetical situation even in the
hypothetical situation that's what I'm
saying I feel like
someone will be like this this bread I
can't be real there will be doubts
everywhere oh okay so you're talking
about corners of the earth you're
talking about the um the pessimism of
humanity yeah yeah cool okay cool yeah
yeah yeah that's why yeah humans are
incredibly pessimistic and that's what's
wrong with the world I want to be lied
to you I want to be so I mean I like to
be optimistic about humans I'm I can be
pessimistic about like stuff other
things yeah when like yeah you might say
something like oh I think this might
happen and I'm pessimistic in terms of
yeah I don't think so
when it comes to people if people tell
me something I want to miss him like
gang yeah like that's cool yeah and if
someone tells me like
why would I ever want to suck another
dick in my life like I just want you
yeah I'm optimistic and like make sense
yes I mean why would you want another
one yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah of course
yeah yeah yeah if someone says that's
the biggest I've had yeah and like any
bigger would split me in two yeah I'm
like yeah facts yeah like 100 you don't
need anyone yeah you don't need anyone
else like I'm perfect yeah I'm perfect
um
so yeah like I'm I'm optimism like that
so like I would I would believe anyone
okay actor actor actress own or or not
yeah I'm
I like to be lied to and I like to
believe the lies what do you think do
you think you'll be you'd find out so
what did he actually say like did he say
oh no so I can't remember specifically
what he said
um but he brought her up in terms of
something to do with like trust but it
wasn't necessarily saying he doesn't
trust her or she doesn't trust him but
something along those lines I can't
remember specifically but it made me
think of that to ask you oh okay I'm
saying um but I feel like do I think I
can tell whether if my partner's lying
to me if she's an actor actress
um I think I'll find it very very very
difficult especially because like that
Ryan Reynolds
um polyphil actor died at least 50
movies or whatever Blake Lively been
active for years series movies so I feel
like they both know how to well not feel
like I'm pretty sure they know how to
just switch on a switch off as and when
they please do you know what I mean yeah
I think so as well but I think it's one
of the things whereas like you also like
kind of like you know in like playing
poker like you can be an amazing poker
player but everyone's got to tell like
actors have
traits that they will use that they have
to call on in order to like either lie
or cry or do something I guess if you've
been with someone that long you would
understand that like this is Hotel she's
trying [ __ ] true yeah but it's like a
normal civilian won't pick up on yeah
and all of a suddenly like she's like
yeah yes I disrespect the thing but
Ryan's seeing that little eye twitch
like this [ __ ] is lying yeah yeah
um but well yeah they seem like a weird
not a weird couple like a weirdly
magnificent couple it's mad because he
was with
um Scarlet before was really I'm sure it
was married to Scarlett Johansson before
his married yeah bro I've been married
all together
what a woman for at least a couple years
and then obviously he's been with Blake
yeah forever now forever yeah yeah yeah
jeez yeah he's he's cleaned up Scotty
yeah I can see why they didn't work
though like I'm obviously speculating
I'm being a little gossip yeah but um
she's too dark for him scar yeah
you know what I mean like DC
in there and Ryan is not about it she
seems a type that will just start an
argument because she wants to get choke
slammed you know what I mean
she just wants to get jokes
she just wants to get roughed up yeah
and Ryan's like what are you doing man
I'm not about this beef frog like what's
all this yeah Blake just wants kids and
love and Care Bears yeah that's what she
wants and runs about it yeah because he
just likes to make like Dad jokes yeah
yeah yeah yeah Scarlett I don't know
what man's built for that I actually
don't know what man's built for that
apart from like obviously me
but yeah she's toxic you can tell
Scottish I can imagine she just says
[ __ ] I used to have the biggest question
oh same bro these are the biggest crush
when um
when she was in uh Justin Timberlake's
video what goes around comes around
to get married afterwards there's too
orgasmic yeah and then I found out he
was with Jessica Biel I was so
disappointed oh obviously they're
married obviously whatever you don't
care less but at that moment I was so
disappointed I was thinking
she was buying it in that video you had
scar joke yeah yeah yeah she was banging
in that video yeah yeah wow she was
cheating that video as well
dark what goes around comes around she
was a notorious cheating at yeah with
his boy and his boy couldn't help
himself
scar Joe bro that's a video it's got Joe
Bro what goes around comes back around
yeah wow wow yeah that was a good song
Good video good album
and then it breaks down
Justin Timberlake's career and Missy
Ellis career I'm Missy Elliott's career
and
oh there's only those two that I know
like prolifically yeah yeah we're all
speaking of Missy Elliott random I was
listening to Jasmine Sullivan's need you
bad the other day random bam Banger
obviously and I've forgot Missy Ellis in
that song just speaking Patois at the
beginning for like five minutes for no
reason she's just in there speaking
Patois yeah neither of them are Jamaican
is so irrelevant to the song that when I
heard it 10 years later I was like what
is this because she does she even have a
verse in there no she says it's just the
beginning I think she just speaks Patty
at the beginning and it doesn't say
anything for the rest I'm thinking what
relevance do you have in this song I'd
be so livid if I paid her for reverse as
well if I paid her if I paid Missy her
future fee I couldn't have to jump on my
breakthrough album
and she's just doing a password for 30
seconds at the start and she's like gang
run me my pee
that's going to get you views and likes
and everything send me my money no no no
no any talent I need any any talent I
need a verse yeah get in between chorus
one and two what are you doing oh god
um right so you've got a dilemma for us
as well today right I do have a dilemma
I think someone
uh what other fans sent me um sent me
this and I thought I'd read out to you
so my wife and I spent our fifth
anniversary in Vegas
she wanted a threesome and I agreed to
it with the first willing stranger
that we met on the strip with the first
willing stranger
wow I wanted a woman she brought her
side due to our bed she paid for his
trip and pretended they had just met
he's bigger than me help
first of all more context needed how did
he find out this is the side dude how
did he find out that she paid for the
trip and why is he not killing everyone
he's bigger than me help help so she
just Okay cool so it's fifth anniversary
she said babes I want to spice it up in
Vegas they flew out they flew out to
Vegas go out to Vegas let's have a
couple drinks what do you think I'm
thinking threesome he says gang gas for
starters gang he never loves you more
than today dust first willing stranger
how about we go outside on the Strip
yeah you want to go I want a guy first
one to say yes we Pat her he says say
less bet because we're not finding that
guy yeah I promise you we're not fine
we're not finding the guy so it's minor
willing to take the risk for the
potential reward yeah
10 seconds in she says excuse me sir you
wanna have a threesome with your husband
he says obviously
I must say wow and he's Wham he's bigger
than he's bigger than me help they get
back to the room he's thinking how did
this happen fam and then there's a
massive chunk of information that we're
missing and he finds out this is your
man it's your side dude this is your
sighting you flew him out he flew him
out to Vegas for our anniversary just so
you can [ __ ] both of us at the same time
you're evil
you're a Shepherd of the devil you're
evil that's mad to me bro and he just
played along with it
once it help
I don't know what kind of some sidemen
have no Pride bro I some sidemen have no
Pride because like I could never receive
a message to say yo me and my
me and my main are going away but I you
know I need that wood yeah yeah I know I
need that word it's a seven day trip I
can't so how about you meet us on day
three we do this whole Lottie
darshenanigans and yeah you come through
and potentially have a threesome of me
and my main thoughts and I look at it
and say yes it's impossible yeah fly me
out to Vegas so I can bang you and your
husband impossible I will wait till
you're back yeah I will fill in the gaps
yeah yeah
she will send me this long thing
justifications and all and then the only
price you would get is that strike one
two more and you're out then that's
strike one I don't know where your
head's at enjoy your anniversary that's
true I'll see you when you get home
that's strike one Rags she would she
would miss you the whole week thank you
yeah I can hear from her again enjoy
your anniversary that's strike one oh
[ __ ] Bro first of all like I'm
down for this whole sneaky LinkedIn yeah
yeah
don't make me disrespect your mind in my
face in his face sorry never don't make
don't make I'm big I know I'm bigger
than him I know what you're achieved
look at me look at me and look at him
again don't make him look at me yeah all
of you come on because I'm on the side
of mandem obviously myself yeah yeah and
when Tom is on the table I'm gonna eat
up yeah but man yeah don't make me eat
in front of your man don't make me eat
off his table in his own yard come on
man
[Music]
He's only seen on TV yeah yeah yeah I'm
dashing her about he can't pick you up
and I'm launching you about the room yo
yo that's treacherous it's his
anniversary too
you know what she's actually taking the
piss and I'm like you know what Sally
it's his anniversary too
full stop yeah yeah it's his anniversary
too think about that
wow yeah wow indeed wow who do you
actually think you are that's my tikka
masala spinning
fan Tesco's finest just spinning and I'm
thinking who does she actually think she
is yeah nuts
think about stuff before you say it to
me nuts bro I can't
I just don't understand why she thought
that would be a good idea because she's
obviously gonna lose both after that oh
one million because there is no there is
no way
let's let's just say
this has gone through like I'm I'm uh
I'm side dude right why do you get to
beside dude well my main or am I yeah
I'm side dude you're main wow
wow that doesn't exist okay well she
exists but she's not here yeah yeah I
don't think there's a way that you as
the main
wouldn't be able to tell that me and um
your Bay have met before because you're
doing stuff that I know she likes
exactly exactly you're doing stuff to
consecutively you're ticking consecutive
boxes that took me six years to find out
and I will probably say something that
she that's only common between you two
in terms of like a nickname or Psalm or
kissing a birth certain you know is is
it just doesn't make sense that you
would do that I'll be like that's a
technique that you don't do with a
stranger like you're gonna spread and
spit and and you know yeah yeah yeah you
know I'd see you bend us as red spread
spit in there wipe down and slide in and
I'll be like hang on
hang on you're either a professional or
you know my wife yeah you've been there
before you've been there before speak up
and that's that's how it starts that's
how the beef starts yeah that's when
that's why my brain will start doing
laps and I'll start stroking you off as
Revenge
because if you want to be here then
let's play because now why
no no no no no yeah what yeah
because I'm upset and I'm heartbroken
and my wife's a cheat okay picture my
mindset yeah yeah yeah since you made me
be mean I'll be mean I'll be your little
man
it's my anniversary yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm up up yeah your guest and it was
obviously her idea to fly out here we're
doing she's she's this is okay think
about the roller coaster emotion and
think about the mental collapse that's
about to happen right okay I'm happily
married yep my wife decides for our
fifth anniversary not our first we've
been in it for a minute now yeah fifth
anniversary let's fly to Vegas to spend
some money and clap some cheeks when
we're there she says let's mix it up and
spice it up let's go chirp some things
downstairs first guy I'll go to say yes
they're coming to bed tonight I'm
thinking I can't believe the woman I
have yeah like how did I get so lucky
how did she loves me all of a sudden
there's some massive prayer in my bed
skip forward half an hour is a massive
prayer his tits are unbearable I
couldn't be happier with his quads and
he got an asset won't quit and I'm
thinking right right
hilarious I don't think you're right
you're analyzing right yeah yeah I'm
drinking you in yeah yeah and I'm
thinking right
[Music]
you were just wandering the strip and
you've agreed to a threesome and you
look like this yeah you look Mosaic yeah
like who built you bro I think this
ain't making sense but whatever and then
obviously you do the spread speed swipe
and in yeah and I'm like
hang on yeah
hang on hang on that was too precise
she's loving it and then yeah you you
call her Satin
Sutton West like SARS
SARS you like that size
swear down and then as you manner in it
I'm doing up algebra yeah yeah Zach
exactly and I'm like swear I've been
lied to this is whole as a whole thing
this is an orchestrated thing this is
her man this is her sighting that she's
actually flown in here to Gate Crash our
anniversary I was up up up crashed down
I'm like okay so we're doing our
threesomes this is what I'm talking to
myself also we're doing threesome let's
do threesomes and I'm like all right Tom
and I squeeze your nipple and twisted
just haha we're playing because you came
to [ __ ] both of us yeah you don't know
me like that because last time I checked
you came to fight both of us yeah yeah
not me this is about me
for your tits come from me come then and
you're trying to play awful cool yeah
come on bro no no no no no no no it's
all good let me help you let me help you
bang my wife yeah
what is that two inches circumference
well played well played stop all that
stuff all that let me have some
give SARS a break how about that without
wood she needs to breathe so let's take
a break says yeah give me that and now
let me let me see something nah let me
see something that says hold your mouth
yes hold your mind
I came for a threesome so that's three
up hold your mans I'm two yeah nah this
is what you wanted bro hold your man or
did you just come into bang my wife so
look me in my eye and tell me what
you're here for did you come in for a
threesome if so give me that uh or did
you just come into bang size I think you
need to talk to your wife so that's why
I'll say I'm not dip yeah I would not
and dip that's cool because I'll let you
I'll be like say less yeah I'm going to
the mini bar and I'm finding something
Sharp
they'll have like a corkscreen yeah hey
I find the size it's going in between my
Knuckles I'm finding something sharp for
you man you man yeah yeah
of course of course
you might not make an eye tonight show
up for you man I'm holding something for
you oh that's jokes yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I'm in fact I'm coming up
behind you it's gonna be in your jugular
why are you what your back shot my
wife's gonna be juggler and I'll say
spread your cheeks no since you liked
yeah since you like to spread and spit
no no no spread something no no you'd
have to kill me yeah yeah
and I will that's fine yeah that's you
have to kill me you men are going to be
screaming for help I couldn't be taken
up about to have my world snatched away
with from me like that because I've got
a nine hour flight home through with her
a car yeah
yeah someone's dying in there someone
everyone's dying yeah because I'm gonna
Mark you man off and I'm jumping yeah
yeah I'm not going home to what yeah
there's nothing there for me risen
they're risen
murk in your amount of jumping out the
window at the Bellagio yeah oh cause she
wanted a dick was this worth it
it is mad
that's nice jokes though anyway guys
that's our episode for today thank you
so much uh shorter and sweeter than
usual but um of course guys let us know
your resolutions let us know keep us
accountable as always guys
um catch us for episode
250 over on patreon on Thursday that's
patreon.com shits and gigs and as always
guys thank you so much for wasting your
time with us love love gang gang gang
bless
[Music]
foreign